[Music]
Oh what is going on YouTube mission
luego
makeup tutorial hi I'm David seller
today I'm gonna teach you how to look
like an ugly [ __ ] huh so as promised
today y'all know what it is it's all
about the people's hater
y'all submitted your stories not
figuring out which one I want to talk
about so y'all gonna know what it is LG
[Music]
[Music]
u geographically stupid [ __ ] is Osama
bin Laden my Apple [ __ ] Egypt is Africa
Jesus come take me away I'm about to go
up Legolas on this [ __ ] like you know I
hate your guts cuz you can't even insult
me properly if you were gonna get at me
you shoulda asked me if I was related to
a pharaoh
if King toughness my homie Oh excited
when the mother 3 came out but you asked
if I was related to a terrorist you love
life a little bit no brain racist cut
nipple lookin mama you know what let's
just say you asked the question in the
right context and I was a terrorist what
would you do then do you think that you
made the right choice my hands of
terrorists if he's a terrorist you try
to get blown up [ __ ] [ __ ] I
shoot a rocket laughs whoo in broad
daylight just to set the consequence
like this yo they're with me I shot it I
had to do it just like this
[Music]
you dumb [ __ ] you broke on me because
of what the math you broke up with me
because you wanted to get young dick
with with Joe where's Shane negative two
inch penis nada
that's why I stole the whole mojo biggie
small [ __ ] especially when it's cold
that [ __ ] [ __ ] reverses to his
stomach like a turtle head and [ __ ] like
this it don't work like that behave you
got mad because I told you to go [ __ ]
yourself well here's two other words
that might scare you child support
that's right you ain't gonna be around
you dead because I don't want my child
around you anyways with your sorry-ass
morals you gonna run away huh take you
to court take you for all your money but
the only way you're gonna be around our
chances if you love him and if you don't
love him then bounce the [ __ ] out you
almost do I'm going to jump in multiple
languages just so you cuss at you
internationally even tell machine cuz
the truth I'm not thank you man I do
[Music]
[Music]
you gonna steal from me [ __ ] stealing
from me for years and guess what is a
[ __ ] mother sometimes woke up in your
stomach oh sorry it's because I sucked
you in yo dick in your sleep that's
right [ __ ] yo sperm is so
scrambled up your baby will come out
throwing up gang signs at the womb like
this take it out of your [ __ ]
[ __ ] you never know the dish meaning
ass [ __ ] you know why the next
time you don't do your [ __ ] dishes
I'm gonna take all the force you use put
in the bag and beat the [ __ ] out you
with it here for me [ __ ] you're having
the left person to stop me you don't
know you because he disappeared let me
ask you something all those little DVDs
and games you still didn't really ask
you out how much you sell that [ __ ] boy
if you won't be a [ __ ] criminal watch
going for your criminal books if we're
straight into [ __ ] like TVs purses
copper wire to the house of [ __ ] [ __ ]
man of course you were still for me
who else will still with me you're the
only person that lives in the house with
me then what the next time you want to
[ __ ] a party you [ __ ] pissed drunk as
[ __ ] I could just let somebody put a
penis me [ __ ] that's right
that's right when that shits going down
nothing like this it turned into cheat
why are you getting your other cheek
turn well that's it for this times
people channa guess what there will be
enough people to later if you guys want
me to continue to do this and help you
guys do with your emotions then let me
know in the comments and
etc etc so I'll see y'all later and keep
on hating people because it makes the
world go round
steady dose of hate already watching
this [ __ ] every day
[Music]
I'm taking on
girl
[Music]
yeah well guess what I percent to her
email Turner all about the weird [ __ ]
that you do that's right
that's right you're [ __ ] your [ __ ]
[ __ ] eatin mother